et vous mathieu c'est quoi la piana
mission tu vas me désole marc cherry
strike de la était pas fou mais au delà
moi moi j'avoue que le show années 80 da
da dam d'un animateur et gris sida
l'animateur est grillé dure ça se voit
ces pharisiens chose c'est ringard à
bondues qui reviennent et au delà de ça
j'aime à dire pas trop bus qui sont la
c8 qui se voulait la puck soeur de
canal+ qui innovait on l'avait vu et que
vous que vous êtes arrivés un peu
camille combal à l'époque et maintenant
on a dû sabatier du lagaf carole
rousseau l'énergie j'adore tous ces gens
là qui sont les jeunes que vous poussez
et sohu leymergie tout ça c'est quoi ces
maisons de retraite ces 8e boisé ont
déconné
tous ceux qui marchent plus ailleurs
broussolle carte cartonnée c'est non pas
du tout cartonner sur tmc karol beck
cartonne chez william leymergie il
marchait pas ou font tout bas mais j'ai
dit ça qui marchait pas oui je dis qu'on
récupère quand même que des gens payés à
un moment c'est quand on est un petit
chêne qui pontoise est faux il faut
attendre le bon moment
hier valérie bénaïm ça fait plusieurs
années qu'elle est avec nous dans touche
pas à mon poste
elle a fait plein de choses avec nous
aujourd'hui elle est en access sur
cevital a dit la vérité
arrêtez de penser à vous mais ce peut
penser plutôt à la chaîne
vous avez aimé d'eau toutes les semaines
avec touche pas à mon people vont monter
en puissance
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez de jalouser toutes les questions
les a déposés assez sûr pourquoi j'ai
pas de price est pas vraie demande des
seconds parce que vous êtes dur et
jardinent la dragnet moubarak va
récupérer des animateurs c'est vrai
qu'ils ont aux tirs ou 40 ans de
carrière sur une chaîne qui se veut ça
l'a montré avec vous qu'il se veut être
un laboratoire pour pousser les petits
je ne m'aimais pas dedans je ne suis
plus un petit jeune si la ritournelle
récupérer tous les matchs nuls et tous
les dinosaures de nous faire aimer la
semaine dernière vous êtes un petit jeu
là
non mais il faut chaud franchement je
dis la vérité aujourd'hui qui vous avez
comme nouveaux talents a pas ceux qui
sont au delà calmes et tous et je vous
le dis il ya un truc qui est dingue
c'est que tous les talents qui émergent
mine de rien beaucoup sont ici ou
d'oubli un canard ou du groupe mais on
va pas dire on va dire la vérité
yann barthès ils étaient où canada et
camille combal et elvis tous les tous
les jours d'huile ya cinq animateurs qui
vont compter dans les prochaines années
yann barthès camille combal 00 eric
antoine
j'en ai parlé hier les mecs et
la gare sont quand même année où on a
serré la nurse et sur les 5
il y en a trois qui viennent de ces 8es
ya peut-être vous mathieu aussi vous
savez qu'on croit beaucoup en vous moi
je crois beaucoup en vaut en tout cas
mais il faut arrêter de prêcher pour sa
paroisse et voilà et aujourd'hui on a
besoin aussi de deux grands de grandes
signatures mais ne rien patrick sabatier
c'est une grande signature vous le dis
oui mais moi mais dont je rêvais
l'opposé l'horloge biologique tourne à
faire avancer bleus ophélie meunier dont
les filles un enfant de canal donc ya
pas que des mecs exactement sa qualité
bur qui ont failli mener aussi masquer
les gardes de kadhafi